oh no oh my god that's all I'm mainly
trying to help on the top of this
mountain lies friendly dragon so today
on let's play Tamar and I are going to
go visit said friendly dragon yeah he's
a good time it's going very well we are
obsessed with The Legend of Zelda
thank you that a hot game hottest game
hottest aiming for Hellboy yeah freezing
on this mountain if you want to see us
being warm though on a tropical island
in a wonderful world of Zelda you can go
watch last week's let's play where we
explore a survival island yeah like
socially same time and also games both
started a new regular series called
Triforce it's great and featuring Peter
Brown and Rob Henry doing cool stuff in
the Legend of Zelda is a game that
facilitates a lot of like fun gameplay
opportunities and we're hoping to
explore them on a regular basis and you
and Robin pyaare that pursue fun guys
yeah that loved loved the game and are
enjoyable to watch so check that out
every week we've got episode 1 on
YouTube while you're there subscribe
like and subscribe like and subscribe so
you never miss an episode of Triforce or
let's play well on trifles I don't
believe they've made of this mountain so
that's what we're gonna do today
I've played through this section which
is why I'm currently using Lucy's switch
because I did it and I was like that
would be a really cool thing to do and
let's play and I was like we've done
this so what are the key challenges
you're going to be facing here in the
heads
isn't this dumb camp I've got our unique
actually boomerang that's the first
challenge so basically this this Oh God
this mountain is a pretty treacherous
climb full of enemies and then at the
top you face sort of a mini boss yeah
and as you can tell already the enemies
on this mountain ain't playing yes
especially when I've got 4 ha
so you ordinarily you can tell from the
amount of damage that this enemy is
taking and your hearts that you probably
shouldn't be here
yeah the other thing that kind of
signifies that might be an area that we
shouldn't be in is that we've had to use
like items to boost our cold resistance
yeah I don't have the right clothing to
really stay here long but I've got like
eight minutes in this cold resistance
I've got another gu I've got another
potion uh give me another 12 with my
potion and stuff oh wow these nodes
that's pretty much how I look what shall
I tell up to Chile's Hill and eyes a bit
too far on each actually gonna pop a
salad can I have a quick salad break
give me some extra hearts I thought this
is a nice contrast last week since it
was sunny there it was nice and sunny
and it was I mean this is kind of like
another desperate fight for survival as
well yeah and it's in its own way
there's a from I've seen so far where I
understand there's three of these dragon
type spirits oh that's my boomerang
there's three of these dragon types
breads all inhabiting like a different
kind of biome shall we say hmm so this
is the only one I've found personally
mmm Oh as well I'm sorry off oh you're a
savage sound of a donkey swing man
alright just run just run my friend be
free it's interesting that you've
decided to engage the enemies on the
strategy given the time pressure I would
be inclined to well that's all my ass up
this mountain I figured that if if I
didn't engage them they're just gonna be
at my back freezing yeah it's it's the
typical dogs whole thing as well isn't
it like what you think I'm just going to
run past these guys and then you turn
around and they're all following you
like oh boy I'm so sorry oh oh my god he
just got in the way I'm gonna take your
meat for a freeze though no it's Bru
Liam Neeson would not be happy yeah well
hopefully we can at least cook it so is
sacrifice to be in vain
cue her energy son your camouflage is
weak look guys I see you
that's ya ever hear she's doing a little
dance awesome
doing AI s'mores I can expect a lot of
my weapons to go through yeah some hell
no no no these guys are not messing
around we also got the time in that
block yet they've got that sick tail
swipe move touch these people off guard
yeah yeah their tongue no looking for
you yes he's angry I'm just trying to be
like extra careful because a our hearts
are not yeah am i saying I've got like
hearts coming out of a loop
Marty basically that's where they go
[Music]
shell lizard is putting up a good fight
it's doing my head in that's what's
doing whoa don't freeze me again make
fun of that running sort of slush hey go
she'll for you
no she'll see you son eat this I fully
expect to get through some weapons in
this er so you'll collect it all yeah I
think my current shields a bit knackered
sona yep in the dirt in the bin
it's boomerang getting closer the dragon
it's a perceptively short climb but man
it's like it's a slog it reminds me of
climbing Thea is it like a thousand
steps in Skyrim oh yeah it's that
arduous climb full of enemies finally
gets the damn top cut remember if
there's anything to eat up here either
there's a dragon mate areas Oh eat that
boy what's got mate
all right you can see it's not very well
yeah he's got some like blisters
something yeah some growth just colors
of it weird yeah I need lemsip
yeah this is one of the moments where I
got to I was like man the art style this
game it's just the bomb the bomb diggity
it really is you have obtained numerous
trials and obtain this robes
that's right I have overcome one you see
before you is it attendant to the spring
of wisdom just three Springs in the game
that's where you find these dragons this
is nature servant of the goddess has
looked over the spirit to slam for ages
unknown to the world of mahan men don't
care about order however the dreaded
malice unleashed by calamity Ganon has
possessed its body and reduced it to
this state looks knackered on it yep you
who have received a spirit orbs free and
a drew it from this malice show um
Howard machine nope I have Sarah all of
a sudden yeah for the one ring on it but
so yeah the objective is I'll turn out
you need to get all these growths off
its back and if you've faced like this
malice stuff before it gains power from
like the eyes you can get rid of it by
going
shooing it's now below ah oh sweet I'm
not big runaround honest so I'm just
going to take off laters early Gators
alright the rest of this our objective
is to free the dragon from its pain you
will chase out the line pretty much used
to get like a good old boost
I gotta climb to the top menu yeah the
all the all the dragons have like a
similar challenge to this I've not
earned that fact I've seen you the two
but it's not always obvious how to get
to them all right this one seems to be
the most most obvious you should mean
you should climb man yeah it's a bit of
a hard climb but follow the path to the
dragon just walk up it it's no big deal
it's just one of those things I think
it's again one of those things the game
doesn't tell you hey there's dragons and
spirits if you give you stuff you should
go and help them but if you venture just
a little bit off the beaten path it's
the game of rewards curiosity yeah
which is like one of my favorite things
about you also he can climb just bits of
ice somehow rain big problem ice no
problem guys not slippery at all as I
always got on his belly there yeah it's
a very Shadow of the Colossus moment in
it yeah when I saw I think it was the
green one I tried to just jump on it and
it was like neither than that Oh a bit
higher oh Jesus was it too close for
comfort I'm trying to help man this is
this is very much like a hare in the
lion yeah trying to get it out your foot
mate good if you go to Gucci oh no oh my
god so I may be trying to help you've
got a long climb back up I have no so
this dragon should come down now come on
man come on don't slip don't slip
there you go don't slip please do the
next line that's off I don't even know
it is it I know just what you're
thinking
I think it's nothing is quite as the
funny please help me oh now chasing the
MOT mothers are my only hope
can you do it yeah buddy
go me nope
it's completely 50 go go okay I've got a
whole bunch Faris yes hey Ethan great
moves
hey Linc keep it up keep it up oh don't
fall there's a hurt
hit me I hit myself again oh sorry oh Sh
sorry I'm hoping there's a dragon Oh God
are the last ones on his other side you
can get that one on it so ass it's gonna
shut or tail whatever you want to call
it that's it open though the eyes not
open are the over open mystery open
first open your damn eye Oh No salmon as
well oh [ __ ] oh please it just blow me
everywhere I got I've lost control
so what the training is called in
neverending story foul call yeah the big
white one yeah I believe so with the
moustache I stopped watching that movie
when I turned like I think I used to
watch as a kid and then I remember
actually asked my mom not to let me
watch it anymore because it made me cry
every time the horse sank into the mud
spoilers for this feel off for the 1980s
a release on it there you go the ass one
is on you need its eyes open shoot
faster yes shoot that booty and ass Oh
buddy
now the way yeah no problems further
boom save the dragon he's like whoa Rosa
laughs the dragon save the world
it's adorable okay yeah some free glowy
as hell now boys look at me say that is
really as [ __ ] is 33 I got it Marco
that we get like a little reward
so any little one then you only save a
dragon I yeah don't get ahead of
yourself can I have the dragon now just
it's your new Mountain Nami thanks to
your efforts nature of the spirit of map
mount land i i'd only keep bringing up
dog shows that looks like coffee and
front but also like when you fight
what's-his-face in the seat the scaler
yes yes it's like a everything is
doctors it's all dark souls a single
ceremony remains now loose your arrow
through the body of nature to free the
spirit of this region when I first did
this I was like this is a gag you want
me to shoot this thing in the face yeah
eat this say oh why did you do that I
thought we were right in the nose I said
I'm leaving it's like when you've got a
push there it's like a sad scene from a
movie where the kids trying to leave his
dog behind you have to kick it or push
it away to be like no no don't follow me
Old Yeller that is that's the spirit
nature of scale if none we ever have an
itch on your back that cut you can't
reach skate boiling so you can't get
that get that natural scale and scratch
it come off at a scale from the Blue
Spirit need rudeness bring your wisdom
this is a lot of free dialog pressure
scale fell from the blues very nature it
contains a bit of cold within so you
need almost in cooking but just eating
it seems like a waste I dare you like
double date you meant to offer it up to
it to the shrine some people just like
not only this late I I did is I'm sure
they have to hold that remember just
marking it down
that's like a go a bit
I know I said this spring didn't it
Chuck in the war look a bit ago I kind
of am curious as to what happens if you
ve hmm oh yeah free try path has shown
itself now go forth now you go forth
don't know what's dude I'm link did you
give it to me back no no Kay so it's
gone me dissolved in the water how weak
a trice like a blocker it's like a
Baraka I should put in water Scott just
fizzes up alright Danijela better
maybe we should reload a save and seeing
what happens if you cook with it I
wonder most chill meals at all time but
would you cook it with taste like heaven
and what what goes the Dragonscale some
reason meant to be like an elixir
instead of a food
Apple Apple and Dragon Scale I'll let
out the spice why would it be spicy
it's dragon in it yeah but it's cold
yeah but bragging that it is cold but
frost bit mate scratches ass again I
love these elemental weapons yeah
unfortunately you lass still haven't
eaten a burger it's still wisely for you
you're wasting away but it's like I
think that's like sixty shrines again
they're all just have like the hunger is
intellectual yes I'm eight that's the
last does a 60th puzzle
you just got to bring him some food yeah
dude it's me honey I'm hungry
anything I saw you kill a wolf on the
way here just give me that I know you
got me gift I don't care that it's got
Pocket lint all over it just let me
pocket link Church us alright so we
gonna load a save and see what happens
if we cook with this thing alright so
we're out cooking pot now yeah hook on
this fresh dragon scale we defeat the
dragon again to get this
well do we combine it with do we just
make like the chillest thing and just
all chill chill so like I see tail and a
white choo-choo jelly and a key swing as
I just call this meal oh I think no I
think we need a critter now I want to
saw the inventory okay we've got a cold
crab a crab
that's stamina crap don't think I've got
any that frog looks like cruising for
eatin that one that one his face
Tyler's frog Titus frog the scale the
shirt right over there yep and I ski
swing and this abettors just make
something discuss the do kid playing
dumb music like a hey is that it that is
this diet that is disappointing to say
the least are you having a giggle that
is has wounded me eyes not worth it all
right well when you get your dragon
scale just give it to the shrine who
know it's sweet tasty reward but I hope
you enjoyed that little let's play
there's a little bit bit of short one
this week we wanted to just share that
it looks dragon adventure with you if
you did enjoy make sure you hit the like
button hit subscribe for more videos
like this one we will see you in the
next one yeah Bruce I'm sure it's gonna
set like autopilot forest on fire
I'm mountains gonna be ablaze whatever
combo no one saw anything